hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
within the self-consciousness section of
Hegel's phenomenology one of the key
developments that he narrates for us
that tells us about the very nature of
our own self-consciousness is what we
can call a doubling and ambiguity
there's a play on words there going on
of consciousness and he's doing this
primarily in paragraphs 178 to 184 this
is prior to the struggle to the death
and the ensuing dialectic of Master and
slave or lordship and bondage that
people tend to focus on but this is a
very important aspect of
self-consciousness that he's revealing
to us the relation to the other is at
the same time a being related to the
other because by the very fact of being
related to another self-consciousness
there's already a mirroring or duality
going on if I am relating myself to that
person out there and and I'm doing it as
sort of another me or somebody similar
in structure to myself as another human
being
they are similarly doing the same thing
in relation to me as well at least at
this stage of the dialectic as Hegel is
narrating so he tells us that
self-consciousness exists in and for
itself only through by existing as such
for an other so this means that
self-consciousness cannot be what it is
without existing in relation to another
another that also relates itself to that
self-consciousness so let's talk very
briefly about this in and for itself
language Hegel uses this quite a bit
he'll distinguish between being in
itself which is the being of an object
you might say a kind of inert being
sometimes it can be dynamic then being
for self which is what we typically do
associate with self-consciousness I
exist
for myself by making my own self an
object for my own thought or my own
action by asking myself what should i do
today I'm already treating myself as
being for self and the goal for Hegel
over and over again is to have these
fuse together in some sort of dynamic
equilibrium or harmony or however you
want to put it Hegel would put it in
terms of a greater unity that that's
thereby attained but this unity cannot
be this is one of the key ideas cannot
be attained except by a kind of duality
a duality of self and other so you can't
have being in itself or being for itself
or both of them without existing as such
for an other it's in a certain sense if
you do have being in itself and being
for itself it's never quite stable you
can't be certain to use Hegel's
favourite term here you can't be certain
of your being in and for self unless it
exists in terms of another and this
brings us to this key notion of
recognition on air kenan in Hegel's
german which is getting fleshed out here
a bit the structure the nature of human
recognition of each other and its
reciprocity so you notice that I have
this nice schema here this will be a bit
useful Hegel tells us as we go through
this that self-consciousness is faced by
another self-consciousness and he says
it has come out of itself and this
introduces to us the when Hegel is
calling the first ambiguity now this is
something I think is worth talking about
the the Greek word that we get ambiguity
from this um be here means both or two
right so when we say something is
ambiguous we don't mean that it's
unclear we mean that it could be
interpreted multiple ways and any
unclarity that comes from that is
precisely because of that ambiguity the
term that a lot of people misuse because
they mistake ambiguity for unclarity or
fuzziness or thing
like that strictly speaking it means
that there's multiple ways to interpret
the situation to make sense other things
the German word really captures as well
doleful the word we get you know is a
cognitive double from doable then then
means meaning or sense so when we say
that a term has more than one sense and
each of those senses is legitimate we
have a double chin or perhaps a you know
a triple or quadruple or whatever sense
but this adequately captures what we're
talking about here because this is the
self-consciousness is trying to figure
out how it exists in relation to the
other self-consciousness so it looks at
the other self-consciousness and Hegel
says in a sense it loses itself because
it goes out of itself and then finds an
other a different person who isn't it
and who is independent of it who could
withhold that recognition who could say
I don't care about you you don't matter
or who are you or whatever other sort of
comportment we can think of on the other
hand it also recognizes the other
self-consciousness as other
self-consciousness precisely by seeing
its own self in that other
self-consciousness so what I put here is
the self of self-consciousness exist
outside of itself in another and there's
desire for that on the part of that that
first self-consciousness that we are
considering in this process so he says
if lost itself or it finds itself as an
other being in doing so it is also
superseded the other this is another key
Hegelian term Alf Haven which we might
think of integrating into a greater
whole or transcending sometimes as
nullifying it's trying to negotiate its
relationship to the other by figuring
out how is that other like itself how
does it find itself in the other in the
eyes
of the other or in the action of the
other or in the desire of the other so
Hegel then starts talking about
ambiguity here and he says you know we
what we have is a first ambiguity right
and we transcend that or supersede that
and that then this super session of
other nough speak um a second ambiguity
what does that mean Hegel is telling us
that there's multiple ways in which this
can be interpreted you could think of
this as a situation in which multiple
resolutions are possible or are
suggesting themselves to the
self-consciousness that is now
confronting engaging hoping for
something from its other who it is
encountering and he goes on and tells us
that it has to supersede the other
independent being in order to become
certain of itself as the essential being
this is integral to Hegel's treatment of
self-consciousness in his view we are
constantly engaging with the other in
such a way as to try to remove the
independence of the other and to have
them fit into the ways in which we see
things the way in which we want things
this is a constant struggle for people
in relationships ranging from romantic
relationships to colleagues at work to
people trying to talk across cultural or
ideological divides this need to to make
the other fit into one's own categories
stems Hegel thinks from a desire to
attain certainty of oneself through the
other and and the other sort of has to
be fixed in place in order to provide
that but there's a paradox here and in
this case it's that well what's this
other doing is the other just taking its
cues entirely from from me and what my
desires are and what I'm telling it or
is this other since it is another me
perhaps more independent than I thought
it was
it also exhibits the exact same agency
the exact same desire the same loss the
same seeing the self in the other there
are two people here two self
consciousnesses confronting each other
and so Hegel goes on and says in
superseding the other I supersede my own
self and I also find out that the other
is doing exactly this same stuff in
relation to me says this movement of
self consciousness in relation to
another self consciousness has been
represented because we had to represent
it in some way as the action of one self
consciousness but the action of the one
has the double significance of being
both its own action and that of the
other as well again this is something
that is really fundamental to human
beings I'll give you a prime example of
how this works
thinking about reciprocity when people
when somebody does something and they
say I'm going to do this and it's going
to affect the other and I want the other
to respond to it in a certain way the
other can come back and say well that's
fine but I'm going to do that too and
then this other over here often times
will say no no I meant it a different
way you know you don't have the same
qualifications or circumstances but this
other over here can say you're really
you know fudging things if it's good for
the goose it's good for the gander as
the old expression goes what we have
there is an ambiguity we have a dull
'pls in we have a double interpretation
one person is you know doing one thing
and saying I need to interpret it this
way the other person is doing the same
thing back and their action is being
interpreted in a different way when it
comes to to impact the first person you
know this is the case of to use another
folk expression people who can dish it
out but can't take it right we say that
of a number of things that is a
reflection of a lack of reciprocity that
he
you'll thinks is quite likely to emerge
from these situations where we have
self-consciousness attempting to attain
certainty of itself in its relationship
to the other what we have to recognize
is that both of these are on each side
so there's a doubling of
self-consciousness as well as an
ambiguity that is taking place he tells
us the other is equally independent and
self-contained there is nothing in it of
which it is not itself the origin this
is a very important thought many people
in their relationship as
self-consciousness is trying to attain
recognition from other self
consciousnesses do not understand that
what they're seeking is inherently
paradoxical what they want is
recognition from a nother and other
self-consciousness who must be
independent in order to actually grant
recognition if they want to be
acknowledged as self-consciousness
existing in and for itself they need to
get that from another being that is
likewise in and for itself and this
applies again to both sides so he goes
on and he tells us the first does not
have the object before it merely as it
exists primarily for desire but
something that has an independent
existence of its own which it cannot
just utilize for its own purposes if I
reduce the other merely to an object of
my desire I lose the other in the
process and do not attain what my desire
is so he says thus the movement is
simply the double movement of the two
self consciousnesses here's where a
mirroring takes place each sees the
other do the same as it does each does
itself what it demands of the other and
therefore also does what it does only
insofar as the other does the same
action by one side only would be useless
because what is to happen can only be
brought about by both that's a very
important consideration there we can't
get what we actually need
in terms of reciprocity by simply
demanding it or by attempting to provoke
it on the one hand exercising our agency
or by receptively trying to seduce it
out of the other there has to be a
mutual recognition taking place
indeterminate circumstances that
acknowledges that both are the other to
the other that acknowledge that both are
motivated by desire that both are
looking for recognition from somebody
who is an equal whether or not that is
possible depends and this is the last
thing that I think we should talk about
here depends for Hegel on what
historical stage of consciousness we
have attained we're going to see that in
the master-slave dialectic where you
don't have a high level of culture to
provide sort of an apparatus to to
mediate recognition the two conte the
two consciousnesses the two self
consciousnesses are going to have to
engage in a struggle to the death one is
going to have to subjugate the other
that is not where Hegel wants to
ultimately go and he thinks that human
civilization has progressed beyond that
not not fully but to the point where at
least some are able to attain
recognition without resorting to that
you